hello everyone and welcome back to the
Capablanca saga I know some of you were
afraid that we are through with the
capablanca saga but that couldn't be
further from the truth
I'd be just weird if we finish the saga
without checking out last converses
capablanca the actual match not the
negotiations which we've covered and if
you are just tuning in to the copper
Blanca saga which you know it's a shame
but it can happen I will put a link in
the description below that will take you
to the playlist covering the entire
kappa blanka saga we've covered so far
and every video we make will be you know
just add it to that playlist so so far
we've covered a few games where capo
Blanco was a child then we covered a few
games in between his match against Cuban
national champion won hordes of them we
went over to the match our famous match
against Frank James Marshall work up a
bunker just obliterated Marshall then we
traveled to a Sun Sebastiaan couple
longest first big international
tournament of 1911 then we've traveled
to son Peter Burke to the big
international tournament of 1914 World
Chess Champion Emmanuel Lasker also
participated and won that event and here
this is also played in st. Peterburg
after the great tournament Capablanca
held a simultaneous exhibition and this
is one of the games that was played
there it's against a gentleman named
Buster of we don't have any other
information about this gentleman only
the name bar stirrup and we don't have a
photo of anything that's why I'm wearing
a hoodie as usual to honor the hoodie
guy and a lot of you have been asking me
in the comments well for a very long
time
most likely since since the beginning of
the Capablanca saga to show a few
Capablanca games that he played against
famous composer sergei prokofiev this
gentleman here and well while we will
show them we do have to do it
chronologically I think that's best but
he's also one of the players that played
in the simultaneous exhibition
Capablanca held and the next video in
the Capablanca saga will be Capablanca
versus say to get Prokofiev so i do hope
you're ready for that and also the
second link the description below will
be our youtube link to best of Prokofiev
if you wanna just you know listen to
some classical music to really get in
the mood for the for the next game in
the couple lanka saga but yeah and
getting back to this game i'm sure
you're all going to enjoy
it's a wonderful game features a very
nice opening and although we don't know
anything about mr. Bosch tariffs we
don't know that he was he was no newb as
he didn't know some opening theory as
you'll see in the game so without
further ado let's check out the game
kappa blanka as this is a simultaneous
exhibition has the white pieces so we
have E 4 E 5 Knight to f3 Knight to c6
and now comes the Bishop to c4 the
Italian game is on the board we have
Bishop to c5 and here comes Janna not
that c3 the Jacobean or the the main
line we have knife to f6
we have d4 the standard line he captures
on d4 that we have seek after son d4 and
Bishop to b4 check Knight blocks check
and now comes Knight captures on e4 and
here kappa blanka just castles and here
already the first moment in the game
where we can really tell that the
pursuit of is not a beginner as he does
know some opening theory here you could
easily fall into a trap of going for 4
for the rook Knight captures pawn
captures Bishop captures and then fall
into the the Greco attack after Bishop
to 83 you could capture the rook and
then rook e1 check just wins the game
there's really not all that much you can
do you can block with the night the King
has nowhere to go the bishop is
controlling the entire diagonal and then
it's just over Bishop captures the Queen
is trapped over here we know that but
still do some opening theory he goes for
Bishop captures on c3 and this is in
fact the best move and Capablanca
doesn't recapture the bishop if he
recaptures then d5 really gives black
just a comfortable game the bishop has
to move black castles the knight comes
into the bishop comes into the game as
just gonna be a very enjoyable position
for black so here Capablanca continues
in great style after Bishop captures we
have d5 now black has to choose whether
he wants to give up the knight or the
bishop it's always better to give up the
night most of the times bishop to f6
offering the night but now again
Capablanca is in no hurry to recapture
the piece first rook to e1
just you know increasing the pressure
developing his pieces there's always
time to recapture the piece Knight the
east
and now just rook captures on e4 we have
d6 by Bushido not allowing any further
advance of the d5 pawn preparing to
develop the light the light square
bishop also black is now ready to castle
we have Bishop to g5 by capablanca
Bishop captures Knight captures and here
black just castles and here it seems
like well the d5 pawn is grabbing a lot
of space in the center for white but
it's also kind of hemming in this light
square bishop so couple Annika will
definitely have to waste at least one
move to activate this bishop on the
other hand it doesn't seem like well
there's there are any problems for black
if black just plays h6 surely all will
be well but here capablanca doesn't
waste time as you can see the rook is
ready to join the attack that the queen
is ready to join the attack but if you
play something like queen h5 just h6
will put the knight back nothing going
on here so here without wasting time
Knight characters on h7 so black has to
decide what to do here of course you
have to capture it's it's the best for
black him King captures on h7 and now
Queen to h5 check King to h8 and now
comes the rook to h4 so pretty much
everyone knew that this was going to
happen white is now threatening Queen to
h7 but also going to h8 checkmate so
what you do here you have to prevent
checkmate somehow in the game f6 was
played f5 would have been better but for
a reason that will well reveal itself
later here black pot f6 now any Queen
check will be met with King to f7 and
also the Queen the King now has an
escape route planned so here kappa
blanka just plays Bishop to d3 and now
you can see that f5 was definitely
better than f6 if f5 would you know was
played there would be no immediate
threat of checkmate now here if white
plays a let's say if black plays
something like Queen te8 then you can go
for the famous checkmating sequence I'm
pretty sure all of you know it the f7 is
covered by the Queen so just bash up to
h7 check King moves Bishop moves now
with check from the Queen King has to
move and now that the bishop is
controlling f7 now Queen to h7 or h8
will be checkmate so already threatening
checkmate with Bishop to d3
like I said FFF I would have been better
here
so rook to e8 buy black you have to
prevent this now Bishop to h7 check will
not be met with King to h8 but rather
King to f8 so here a couple Monica has
to increase the pressure rook to e1 and
excellent move again if black plane if
black makes a slow move let's say Queen
here then you play rook captures on e7
now the rook also controls the f7
squared this is again the threat of
checkmate and if you capture the rook
once again you get Queen 2hh check King
here and now how do you continue the
attack I'm sure you all can see it even
without pausing the video I imagine but
if you need to you know feel free to do
it
Bishop to g6 check the scores covered by
the pawn these scores are covered by the
Queen the King has to capture the bishop
and now of course Queen to h5 will be
checkmate you always have to when you're
trying to find the checkmate like this
you always have to see this this is what
always helps me if if there's something
blocking the King from one square in
front of him and one square to the side
then any check will be checkmate if it's
delivered here by the Queen so there's
that
so here black must waste a move he plays
f5 blocking the bishop and now
Capablanca just brings the rook into the
game rook to e6 a wonderful rook lifts
again if Bishop captures then pawn
captures now the pawn controls f7 and
although this would have been blacks
best bet it's still a very uncomfortable
position again the Queen's are
threatening checkmate you have to give
up the night at least create some
squares for your king and after Queen to
h7 check King moves now the Queen can
capture on g6 and after black tries to
exchange Queens you can even do this
captures captures an hour after Bishop
captures black will have a terrible
position you will not be able to develop
any of your pieces if the rook tries to
come into the game locate Jade check
picks up the other rook you will never
get rid of this pawn it's on a nice
light square protected by a light square
Bishop rook is coming to h7 you can just
start you know cleaning up all the other
points or you don't even have to you
don't want to allow black the chance to
activate you can just move your rook and
then start pushing the King side pawns a
lot of ways too white can go about this
so the this would basically be a very
slow death again
Capablanca so after rook to e6 Vashti
Rove who was no beginner I I have to add
played Bishop to d7 but Bishop to d7
although you know it's a move Black has
to play something it doesn't work white
actually has a force checkmate in in in
four moves so this time feel free to
pause the video and try to find the
winning sequence for white I'll give you
a couple of seconds for those of you who
are able to do it congratulations you
are you are an excellent finder of
beautiful meeting sequences and for
those if you just want to enjoy show
once again the theme of the game is you
know control the f7 square so here
capablanca does it look to f6 now the
rook controls the f7 square again the
threat is Queen to h8 checkmate or door
to h7 and well the most obvious move is
just pawn captures rook but then it's
just you know
checkmate Queen a shade chair king of
seven roof checks king g6 and Queen g7
will be now checkmate so this is one
such idea and there's no other idea in
any other move you play also ends in
checkmate any sneak in ig6 ideas so
we'll also be met with the just win - h7
checkmate so there is no way to avoid it
so yeah rook to have six just a
wonderful one rule I mean every move
cover Monica played here is just
wonderful starting from 97 just a just a
beautiful attack captures characters
check check forces not a will force now
checkmate you have to prevent it black
mate system like it makes a slide deck
act in accuracy pawn to f5 would have
been better
again threatens checkmate with Bishop to
d3 black stops it again threatens check
my dude rope to e1 black stops it and
again rook to e6 just a stifling move
you don't have a good way to avoid it
other than the slow death we've shown
and here after this is just rook f6
it was in this position that first tier
of mr. hua guy resigned the game and
just a wonderful game a couple Blanca
played in this 1914 simultaneous
exhibition in st. Peterburg assume for
the next game we already mentioned we
are going to show couple Blanca versus
Sergei Prokofiev I do hope you will
enjoy this game as well and like I said
yeah I've been listening to
some Prokofiev composing for for today
and at the first thing in the
description ball will be a link to
there's a youtube video called best of
Prokofiev a lot of compositions you can
listen to they're really just great you
know feel free to get in the mood for
for the next game in the Capablanca
series yeah that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it and that you're enjoying
my coverage of the kappa blanka saga so
far i would like to thank Ellie Martinez
Raymond Letta a Ruben Carlo Benante from
stone and man and shag Rose for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos see
are thankful for watching and I will see
you soon there will be one video in
between of the next game in the Kappa
Lanka series I've acquired the PGN of a
chess game played by Arnold
Schwarzenegger and I'm gonna be covering
that today because it's you know just I
think it's the only game so far known
that that he played that we actually
have the moves too so if you have any
ideas of a good title for that game you
know feel free to you know share it
share in the comments below thank you
all and I'll see you soon